the United States and the Islamist
Taliban militia are blaming each other
for the collapse of Afghan peace talks
after Donald Trump abruptly canceled a
planned secret summit with the
insurgents near Washington the two sides
had been holding weeks of lower-level
talks in Doha to seek an end to Afghans
decades of conflict now Trump broke off
those talks after a US soldier was
killed in a Taliban attack over the
weekend the body of an American soldier
returns home sergeant Ellis barreto
Ortiz was the 16th US service member
killed in Afghanistan this year one of a
dozen people who died when a Taliban car
bomb exploded on Thursday near the US
Embassy in Kabul that inspired President
Trump to tweet an unexpected
announcement the major Taliban leaders
and the President of Afghanistan were
going to secretly meet with me on Sunday
unfortunately in order to build false
leverage they admitted to an attack in
Kabul that killed one of our great
soldiers I immediately cancelled the
meeting and called off peace
negotiations it has been 18 years since
the u.s. invaded Afghanistan after the
September 11th attacks on New York City
by its ally al Qaeda thousands of
coalition troops have died as well as
tens of thousands of Afghan troops and
civilians Afghanistan's government has
been critical of the negotiations
between the u.s. and the Taliban which
have largely sidelined spokesmen
welcomed Trump's announcement for any
peace process meanwhile the Taliban said
the decision will harm the u.s. more
than anyone else but seem to leave the
door open to more talks Trump has
pledged to withdraw the remaining 14
thousand US troops from Afghanistan but
he faces resistance from the government
in Kabul as well as from some US
lawmakers who say it's too early to
leave the Afghans on their own let's get
more on this story now we are joined by
DW Sandra Peters Minh
who has been following the latest
developments and you know as we've heard
there the Taliban actually reacted to
this saying that canceling the peace
talks would harm the United States more
than anyone else what exactly do they
mean by that is that a threat I would
say yes definitely it is a threat they
just carry on fighting as we speak now
Sarah there are serious clashes in two
northern provinces of Afghanistan so the
war hasn't stopped why the negotiations
were on and now we can see an even
bigger uptick in violence in Afghanistan
and the threat is look we are ready to
fight probably longer than you do this
is quite a turnaround especially bearing
in mind the fact that the tribal
administration said that it was on the
verge of reaching a deal in these talks
US Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
underlined that again I just want to
have a listen to what he said and then
get your reaction thereafter we were
making real progress towards that we had
a commitment from the Taliban to make a
formal public announcement that they
would break with al Qaeda something that
an American demand that had gone back as
far as President Bush we were making
progress along the way President Trump
was supportive of those efforts so how
close were they really I think they were
really very close on the threshold an
agreement in principle those were the
words of the special negotiator of the
United States and then there was this
last minute turnaround
president Trump looking for a grand
gesture in Camp David but that was
called off very last
and as it is emerging now probably the
cause of rifts within his own
administration secretary compiled being
of a different opinion and the National
Security Advisor Bolton who seems to be
against any kind of deal with the
Taliban given that internal dynamic I
mean we have this campaign president
from US President Donald Trump saying
that he will withdraw American troops
from Afghanistan as soon as possible
realistic at this point I never thought
that was a realistic goal I think it's a
bad idea to rush into any kind of peace
negotiations because you are wanting to
keep a campaign promise we should look
at realities on the ground in
Afghanistan and that is basically trying
to solve a conflict 18 years with US
involvement but if you look at
Afghanistan as a whole we look at four
decades of conflict it's really rather
complicated in Afghanistan and rushing
out seems to be a really bad idea no
easy solutions indeed DWS under fuse
Minh thank you